comme tu peux nous présenter tous les
chroniqueurs et invités par dix ses
parties prenantes à thionville à ces
partis avec grand plaisir
alors sauf ce soir mais c'est le seul à
mettre une cravate d'habitude dans
l'émission alors pas pour le style mais
comme ces divorces lui coûte une blinde
en plus de tpm pays il fait chauffeur
rubber c'est bon j'ai ma carte
[Applaudissements]
elle est depuis le début aux côtés de
cyril hanouna un petit peu comme la
brigade financière et nicolas sarkozy
[Applaudissements]
il s'est mis depuis peu au théâtre et il
a proposé lui même de frapper les trois
coups avec sa table le quatrième s'il
avait autant de charisme que de
vocabulaire riche après tout ce qui
bouge maxime vieu
[Musique]
il s'est pris une pizza par joey starr
une tour par thierry ardisson manque
plus qu'une flammekueche et il peut
ouvrir un resto c'est gilbert d'air
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bravo à c'est un peu la maman de tpm p
heureusement c'est pas la styliste
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
celui-là entre passer du temps la
bibliothèque est passé du temps à la
salle de sport malheureusement il a fait
son choix
c'est matthieu delormeau la prochaine la
légende veut qu'elle parle plus sur ces
photos instagram que dans tpm p
[Applaudissements]
à bientôt pour des activités la de
partout où j'ai vu là allez partout
partout partout alors monette des images
de son émission à vous montrer temps
morts défilé sur aucun élève au call tv
vous allez voir c'est fort well as une
grosse actu et jean luc lemoine c'est le
meilleur ami de cyril hanouna il a
beaucoup duo c'est pas son coiffeur non
c'est jean luc lemoine et pour terminer
c'est la djette de tpm peut en revanche
aura qu'un la prévenir c'est patiner
sont pas branchés ses qualités
[Musique]
merci d'être avec nous